Shure:  土豆
Shure: Potatoes.
Katrina:  土豆侠吃土
Katrina: Potato guy eats dirt.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: There's another one here.
Shure:  以塔塔ki马斯
Shure: Itadakimasu.
Alice: 他够不到
Alice: He can't reach it.
Alice: 我们挪一下啊
Alice: Let's move it a bit.
Alice: 那边还有一个
Alice: There's another one over there.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  我靠 6张披萨
Shure: Whoa, six pizzas.
Tasha: 天不是吧
Tasha: Oh my gosh, really?
Lucia: 哎哎为什么会是6个披萨呢
Lucia: Hey, hey, why are there six pizzas?
Jake: 买2赠2啊
Jake: Buy 2, get 2 free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Alice: 啊现在有那个活动
Alice: Ah, now there's that event.
Lucia: 但我们不是买了
Lucia: But didn't we buy...
Lucia: 就是我还以为是我们买4个
Lucia: I thought we bought four, and two of them were free.
Lucia: 其中有两个是送的呢
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: 不行
Alice: No way.
Alice: 我想在这
Alice: I want to be here.
Katrina:  从未打过这么富裕的仗
Katrina: I've never been in such a wealthy battle.
Katrina:  这么多箱子
Katrina: So many boxes.
Jake: 对流水席
Jake: Yes, a continuous feast.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh, right.
Katrina:  可以站在这边站着吃吧
Katrina: Can we stand here and eat?
Jake: 站着吃吧
Jake: Let's eat standing.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Or else...
Katrina:  行啊
Katrina: Sure!
Shure:  要不我们什么击鼓传花停哪就
Shure: How about we play hot potato, and wherever it stops...
Shure:  哈哈哈就吃哪啊
Shure: Haha, that's where we eat!
Jake: 那你把你的音箱拿上来
Jake: Then bring your speaker up here.
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Jake: 手套可以
Jake: Gloves will do.
Tasha: 嘿嘿机械
Tasha: Hehe, mechanical.
Shure:  没开是吗
Shure: Is it not turned on?
Katrina:  我说开了
Katrina: I said it's on.
Katrina:  我看有多少电量
Katrina: Let me check the battery.
Katrina:  要不要充一会
Katrina: Should we charge it for a while?
Tasha: 嗯谢谢
Tasha: Hmm, thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我亮了吗
Katrina: Am I lit up?
Shure:  你亮着
Shure: Yes, you are.
Lucia: 三个多余的哈哈哈
Lucia: Three extra ones, hahaha.
Alice: 可以开始了吗
Alice: Can we start now?
Lucia: 可以尝尝
Lucia: You can taste it.
Jake: 我先吃也行
Jake: I can eat first too.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大问题不大
Jake: No big deal, no big deal, no big deal.
Jake: 一切都充满着变化
Jake: Everything is full of change.
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Haha, no big deal.
Tasha: 早知道点两个榴莲了
Tasha: If I knew earlier, I'd have ordered two durians.
Jake: 子涵喝水
Jake: Zihan, drink some water.
Jake: 你喝哪一个
Jake: Which one are you drinking?
Jake: 几号
Jake: Which number?
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Tasha: 我刚才想买4个的话是会不会不够
Tasha: I was thinking if I buy 4, would it be enough?
Tasha: 他这是九寸的
Tasha: This one is nine inches.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  连晚饭都解决了
Katrina: Even dinner is sorted.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 啊也好
Jake: Ah, that's good too.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  一会自己操作一下
Shure: Try doing it yourself in a bit.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yep, yep.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 嗯这边都是什么管家代取了
Jake: Hmm, here everything is picked up by the housekeeper.
Jake: 就是请我
Jake: They ask me.
Jake: 我让他们取一下吧
Jake: I'll let them pick it up.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 那我告诉你号码还是什么呀
Jake: So should I tell you the number or what?
Alice: 要榴莲的吗
Alice: Do you want durian?
Jake: 53愈合期
Jake: 53 recovery period.
Jake: 53还是您
Jake: 53 or you.
Jake: 您要什么呀
Jake: What do you want?
Katrina:  喝了咖啡
Katrina: Had coffee.
Jake: 打电话吧
Jake: Call then.
Katrina:  你的食欲会下降
Katrina: Your appetite will decrease.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 好就是我们其实3031栋
Jake: Okay, so we are actually in building 3031.
Jake: 玉河区31栋
Jake: Yuhe District, building 31.
Jake: 玉河区31 啊
Jake: Yuhe District 31, ah.
Jake: 玉河区31
Jake: Yuhe District 31.
Jake: 佑佑的院子
Jake: Youyou's yard.
Jake: 啊可以可以对
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, right.
Jake: 嗯好嘞好嘞谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, okay, thanks.
Tasha: 饱了保护我自己了
Tasha: Full, took care of myself.
Katrina:  披萨好管饱的
Katrina: Pizza really fills you up.
Shure:  感觉吃了一半就已经饱了
Shure: Feels like I'm already full after half.
Tasha: 吃了两片
Tasha: Ate two slices.
Katrina:  带出去野餐吧
Katrina: Let's take it out for a picnic.
Tasha: 嗯带出去野餐吧
Tasha: Hmm, let's take it out for a picnic.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  走累了搞搞个那野餐
Katrina: When we're tired of walking, we can have the picnic.
Katrina:  那一坐就开始吃
Katrina: Just sit down and start eating.
Katrina:  吃完又走
Katrina: And keep walking after we finish.
Jake: 吃不完带走
Jake: If we can't finish, we'll take it with us.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 再去采风是吧
Tasha: Then we'll go sightseeing again, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, yeah.
Jake: 这个应该可以吃完
Jake: We should be able to finish this.
Tasha: 应该可以吃完
Tasha: We should be able to finish it.
Jake: 不是就是今天的时候
Jake: I mean, today, we won't waste it like before.
Jake: 嗯不会像之前一样丢掉
Jake: Yeah, we won't throw it away like last time.
Jake: 丢到第二天就没有用了
Jake: If we leave it for the next day, it's useless.
Shure:  煤气高钙
Shure: Gas is expensive.
Shure:  不能浪费食物
Shure: We shouldn't waste food.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 瘦了吧唧
Alice: So skinny.
Shure:  看我昨天还看的那个梗
Shure: Look at the joke I saw yesterday.
Shure:  然后就是绑着他强制喂他吃榴莲披萨
Shure: And then tying them up and force-feeding them durian pizza.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为是
Lucia: I thought it was...
Lucia: 夏威夷披萨呢
Lucia: Hawaiian pizza.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost.
Tasha: 榴莲披萨
Tasha: Durian pizza.
Tasha: 这么好吃
Tasha: It's so delicious.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是意大利人看到给披萨上放水果
Lucia: Italians see fruits on pizza and freak out.
Lucia: 会非常的崩溃
Lucia: They'll be very upset.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  咱们饺子里面放水果给你吃一样
Shure: Like putting fruits in dumplings for you.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 他们传统披萨上面是不放水果的
Lucia: They don't put fruits on traditional pizza.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure:  肉夹馍突然给你加了一个番茄酱
Shure: Like adding ketchup to a meat sandwich.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 没关系我觉得番茄酱蘸什么都好吃
Tasha: It's okay, I think ketchup tastes good with everything.
Lucia: 肉夹馍为什么要放番茄酱
Lucia: Why put ketchup on a meat bun?
Tasha: 丰富口感吧
Tasha: To enhance the flavor, I guess.
Lucia: 异端
Lucia: Blasphemy.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on saozi noodles.
Lucia: 臊子面放cheese
Lucia: Cheese on saozi noodles.
Lucia: 但这我怎么觉得还好
Lucia: But somehow, I think it's fine.
Lucia: 还可以接受
Lucia: I can accept that.
Tasha: 我也可以接受
Tasha: I can accept that too.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on saozi noodles.
Lucia: 还有美国的那种做成甜了的披萨
Lucia: And there's that American sweet pizza.
Lucia: 好像意大利人也会觉得很崩溃
Lucia: I think Italians would be horrified.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 今天还有布朗尼披萨吗
Tasha: Do they still have brownie pizza today?
Lucia: 你猜吧哦买噶
Lucia: Guess what, oh my God.
Jake: 今晚做一个
Jake: Let's make one tonight.
Tasha: 啊我说达美乐的时候啊
Tasha: Oh, I meant when I said Domino's.
Jake: 真他有啊
Jake: They really have it.
Tasha: 他有啊
Tasha: They have it.
Lucia: 他有
Lucia: They have it.
Jake: 他真的有
Jake: They really have it.
Lucia: 达美乐有这个味
Lucia: Domino's has that flavor.
Tasha: 布朗尼的
Tasha: Brownie flavor.
Tasha: 还有各种各样甜的披萨
Tasha: And all kinds of sweet pizzas.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you eat durian?
Jake: 吃吃吃草本草本谢谢您
Jake: Eat, eat, eat, herbal, herbal, thank you.
Shure:  你好像触发了什么
Shure: You seem to have triggered something.
Shure:  NPC对话
Shure: NPC dialogue.
Jake: 去去去
Jake: Go, go, go.
Shure:  稍等稍等
Shure: Hold on, hold on.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha: 他是那天唯一一个点那个榴莲汉堡的
Tasha: He was the only one who ordered that durian burger that day.
Tasha: 跟我一起
Tasha: With me.
Jake: 一些珍贵的人类吃披萨镜头
Jake: Some precious footage of humans eating pizza.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Lucia: 眼镜怎么这两天又开始疯狂的往下滑
Lucia: Why are my glasses slipping down like crazy these days?
Jake: 这两天瘦了
Jake: You've lost weight these days.
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 不能吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  这都吃瘦了
Shure: This has made us lose weight.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 吃瘦了
Jake: Lost weight.
Jake: 太辛苦了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake: 剧组太辛苦了
Jake: The crew is working too hard.
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  我们这剧组
Shure: Our crew.
Jake: 把人这两天把人吃瘦了
Jake: Just these two days have made everyone lose weight.
Lucia: 哈哈不至于吧
Lucia: Haha, it's not that bad.
Shure:  供吃供住
Shure: We provide food and lodging.
Tasha: 能不瘦吗哈哈哈
Tasha: How could we not lose weight, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We.
Jake: 这个有问题
Jake: This is a problem.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake: 我记一下
Jake: I'll write it down.
Tasha: 大家只能挤着一起吃披萨
Tasha: Everyone has to squeeze together to eat pizza.
Tasha: 而不是一个人娱乐
Tasha: Instead of enjoying alone.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Tasha: 就已经已经遭受不公平的待遇了
Tasha: We've already suffered unfair treatment. 社会问题
Jake: 不是就
Jake: It's not just...
Shure:  这段数据要删掉
Shure: This segment needs to be deleted.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 小心小心你这个
Jake: Be careful, be careful with this.
Jake: 增加我们很多工作量啊
Jake: It adds a lot of work for us.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 我要记一下
Jake: I need to write it down.
Lucia: 啊什么要删掉
Lucia: What needs to be deleted?
Lucia: 吃披萨吗
Lucia: Eating pizza?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha: 12.09
Tasha: 12.09.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 受了不公平的待遇
Tasha: Suffered unfair treatment. 社会问题
Shure:  你看你又说了一遍
Shure: See, you said it again.
Shure:  他又在说
Shure: He’s saying it again.
Shure:  逼逼一句
Shure: One more sentence.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It’s okay, it’s okay.
Jake: 就这这逼逼逼逼逼的
Jake: Just this, this beep beep beep.
Jake: 你们继续吃你们的
Jake: You guys keep eating.
Jake: 但是边吃边逼逼逼
Jake: But eating while complaining
Lucia: 那
Lucia: So
Lucia: 我们之前出现了多少要被道德词汇
Lucia: How many moral words did we use earlier?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: F word的是不是也要
Lucia: Do we need to censor the F word too?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina:  昨天还看到直升机了
Katrina: Saw a helicopter yesterday
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Oh, right
Katrina:  军用的
Katrina: Military one
Lucia: 对军用的是不是会侵占他的版权啊
Lucia: Yeah, will using military footage infringe on copyright?
Shure:  看一眼
Shure: Let's check it out
Tasha: 我们昨天放的电影
Tasha: The movie we watched yesterday
Tasha: 要不要删掉
Tasha: Should we delete it?
Lucia: 我忘了
Lucia: I forgot
Shure:  咱们昨天吃火锅没戴眼镜
Shure: We didn't wear glasses while eating hotpot yesterday
Katrina:  哦空调遥控器呢
Katrina: Oh, where's the air conditioner remote?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah
Katrina:  不想看来着
Katrina: Didn't want to look
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's fine, it's fine
Katrina:  薇薇
Katrina: Tasha
Katrina:  昨天那个空调遥控器是不是在你那
Katrina: Was the air conditioner remote with you yesterday?
Katrina:  薇薇嗯遥控器
Katrina: Tasha, yeah, the remote
Tasha: 不在我那
Tasha: Not with me
Tasha: 我说放在外面的桌上了
Tasha: I said I left it on the table outside
Shure:  空调遥控器
Shure: The air conditioner remote
Katrina:  2楼不通风有点热
Katrina: It's hot on the second floor, no ventilation
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Here it is
Lucia: 这俩是同一个味吗
Lucia: Do these two taste the same?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 可能你加了之后
Tasha: Maybe after you added it
Tasha: 我又不小心又加了一遍
Tasha: I accidentally added it again
Lucia: 不不不
Lucia: No, no, no
Lucia: 有哪位宝宝需要餐巾纸吗
Lucia: Does anyone need napkins?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh
Lucia: 需要吗
Lucia: Need any?
Tasha: 等一下就需要
Tasha: We'll need it in a bit.
Lucia: 那我先放在你这里
Lucia: I'll just leave it here for now.
Tasha: 哦我这怎么了
Tasha: Oh, why with me?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  哦不
Shure: Oh no.
Alice: 下雪了
Alice: It's snowing.
Tasha: 大家够用吗
Tasha: Does everyone have enough?
Lucia: 要
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Shure:  张万森下雪了
Shure: Zhang Wansen, it's snowing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  我再来一张吧
Katrina: I'll take another one.
Lucia: 如果谁需要纸可以传递一下
Lucia: If anyone needs paper, just pass it around.
Shure:  是带那个
Shure: Is it the one with...
Shure:  洗洁精的湿巾是吗
Shure: The wet wipes with dish soap?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  哈哈我擦擦
Shure: Haha, I'll wipe it.
Alice: 对了
Alice: By the way...
Shure:  怎么感觉味不对
Shure: Why does it smell weird?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再舔起泡了
Katrina: Hahaha, it's bubbling up.
Lucia: 哎什么东西
Lucia: Hey, what's this?
Lucia: 带洗洁精
Lucia: It has dish soap?
Alice: 那个厨房湿巾
Alice: Those kitchen wet wipes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 咂嘴
Alice: Yep.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 一个宝贵的数据
Alice: It's a valuable piece of data.
Shure:  哎我记得我刚才掉了一块肉在这
Shure: Hey, I remember I dropped a piece of meat here.
Shure:  怎么找不到了
Shure: Why can't I find it?
Jake: 掉什么了
Jake: What did you drop?
Jake: 掉披萨了啊
Jake: Did you drop pizza?
Shure:  啊不是那个有一块
Shure: No, it was a piece of meat.
Shure:  刚才掉了一块肉
Shure: I just dropped a piece of meat.
Shure:  我记得掉地下了
Shure: I remember it fell to the ground.
Shure:  掉下找不到了
Shure: I can't find it.
Shure:  行了留给蟑螂先生了
Shure: Guess it's for Mr. Roach now.
Lucia: 为什么你们
Lucia: Why do you...
Tasha: 每个盘都送的好均匀啊
Tasha: Distribute everything so evenly?
Shure:  一两个两个两个
Shure: One, two, two, two.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Katrina:  他俩不是一个
Katrina: They're not the same.
Alice: 所以这个是
Alice: So, this one is...
Katrina:  我要问一下他是讲新课还是讲复习课
Katrina: I need to ask if he's teaching a new lesson or a review lesson.
Katrina:  这个得等他回来才知道
Katrina: We'll have to wait for him to come back to find out.
Tasha: 要不要把整盒整盒
Tasha: Should we put the whole box together?
Jake: 好啊拼一拼
Jake: Sure, let's put it together.
Tasha: 这俩可以直接拼过来了
Tasha: These two can be put together directly.
Tasha: 把这个拼在一起
Tasha: Put this together.
Tasha: 对这好像就差两块
Tasha: Yeah, it's only missing two pieces.
Jake: 这就是什么什么
Jake: This is like...
Jake: 油泼面拌臊子面
Jake: Oil-splashed noodles mixed with minced meat noodles.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 必胜客经典二合一
Lucia: Pizza Hut's classic combo.
Jake: 这二合一确实很好
Jake: This combo is really good.
Lucia: 不行我现在站不起来了哈哈
Lucia: I can't get up now, haha.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢好了
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you, all done.
Jake: 嗯挺好
Jake: Hmm, pretty good.
Tasha: 还好把榴莲的都吃完了
Tasha: Good thing we finished the durian ones.
Tasha: 不然他会污染别的味道
Tasha: Otherwise, it would contaminate the other flavors.
Lucia: 好热好热
Lucia: So hot, so hot.
Jake: 榴莲还是可以吃完的怎么了
Jake: Durian can still be finished, what's the matter?
Jake: 哦好热
Jake: Oh, it's hot.
Lucia: 可能是二楼没有那么透气的
Lucia: Maybe the second floor isn't as ventilated.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 对只有只有卧室的窗户好像能打开
Lucia: Yeah, only the bedroom window seems to open.
Lucia: 大厅的都打不开
Lucia: The living room windows can't be opened.
Alice: 想用一下
Alice: Want to use it.
Jake: 好收溜
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Jake: 收丢上礼物上链接
Jake: Pack it up, put the gift link up.
Lucia: 这俩叠一块吧
Lucia: Stack these two together.
Shure:  这个改过的
Shure: This has been modified.
Shure:  结构大概是这个样子
Shure: The structure is roughly like this.
Lucia: 我们的垃圾袋啊在那边
Lucia: Our trash bags are over there.
Lucia: good
Lucia: Good.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  good
Katrina: Good.
Lucia: 等等我
Lucia: Wait for me.
Lucia: 好像已经好几天没有打卡
Lucia: 我的duolingo了
Jake: 学学什么呢
Lucia: 德语
Jake: 德语
Jake: 学德语干啥
Lucia: 比较喜欢哦
Jake: duo lin go是不是你很久没上
Jake: 他就会把图标变得很丑
Lucia: 呃对
Jake: 就是就真的会很就变
Jake: 会变吗你变了吗
Lucia: 会变
Lucia: 就是如果说你好好久不去上课的话
Lucia: 他就会变成要么在睡觉的表情
Jake: 哦
Lucia: 要么就变成沙漠里的一个鸟骷髅
Jake: OK
Lucia: 然后如果你每天打卡的话
Lucia: 他就会非常开心
Lucia: 那个表情
Lucia: That expression
Lucia: 如果你某一天当天没有打卡
Lucia: If one day you forget to check-in
Lucia: 他就会就是呈现一个怒火的表情哦
Lucia: It will show an angry face
Lucia: 真的很有意思
Lucia: It's really funny
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Shure:  这是真没有
Shure: That's really true
Lucia: 我觉得我最大的乐趣不来自于学语言
Lucia: I think my biggest fun doesn't come from learning languages
Lucia: 来自于观赏他
Lucia: It comes from watching it
Lucia: 这个图标设计
Jake: 可以
Jake: Alright
Jake: 嗯管家什么时候
Jake: Hmm, when is the butler
Jake: 我也不知道管家什么时候
Jake: I don't know when the butler
Jake: 问话要
Jake: Will ask questions
Jake: 大伙看看自己眼镜还有多少电
Jake: Everyone, check how much battery your glasses have left
Jake: 要不要插充电宝
Jake: Do you need to plug in a power bank?
Jake: 时间差不多了
Jake: It's almost time
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 条件反射的算一下
Lucia: Reflexively count it
Lucia: 估算一下大家的饭量以后好点
Lucia: Estimate everyone's food intake for later
Lucia: 天呐谐音梗扣分哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, deduct points for puns, haha
Lucia: 没有反应过来
Lucia: I didn't realize it.
Tasha: 我这怎么3.8块钱
Tasha: Why is it 3.8 yuan for me?
Tasha: 一签字你怎么3块钱一签字
Tasha: Once you sign, why is it 3 yuan per signature?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha: 嗯，所以
Tasha: Uh, so...
Tasha: 我就是搜的一模一样他要我106块4
Tasha: I searched for the exact same thing, and it costs me 106.4 yuan.
Tasha: 嗯这两次尝尝价格不一样人家会说吧
Tasha: Um, if we try it twice and the prices are different, people will talk, right?
Tasha: 不知道呀而且跟你刚刚的界面一模一样
Tasha: I don't know, and it looks exactly like your interface just now.
Jake: 子豪我们再看一下充电宝吧
Jake: Nicous, let's check the power bank again.
Jake: 对你你查
Jake: Yes, you, you check.
Tasha: 所以要不还是你查吧
Tasha: So, maybe you should check.
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Check again.
Tasha: 我真的已经打开了
Tasha: I really have it open already.
Shure:  这是重要素材
Shure: This is important material.
Shure:  所以不可丢不可遗失
Shure: So it can't be lost or misplaced.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 对他要在下午2点钟之前要 我们查完之后看
Tasha: Yes, he needs it before 2 PM. After we check, see if it's less than 10%.
Tasha: 有没有低于10%
Tasha: See if it's less than 10%.
Tasha: 安好吗好
Tasha: Okay, okay, alright.
Tasha: 好好拜拜
Tasha: Alright, bye-bye.
Katrina:  捕梦网是不是
Katrina: It's a dreamcatcher, right?
Lucia: 哦没有就是
Lucia: Oh, no, it's just...
Lucia: 是对但是跟海有关
Lucia: Yes, but it's related to the sea.
Lucia: 就我想的是
Lucia: So I was thinking...
Lucia: 可能做成地中海风格的那种
Lucia: Maybe make it in a Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 蓝白的颜色
Lucia: Blue and white colors.
Lucia: 但我发现我现在买的材料都是白的
Lucia: But I found out all the materials I bought are white.
Lucia: 还没有蓝材料呢
Lucia: There's no blue material yet.
Alice: 如果你想做地中海风格
Alice: If you want to do a Mediterranean style...
Alice: 我可以把高中的老师捐给你
Alice: I can donate my high school teacher to you.
Lucia: 把高中老师捐给我
Lucia: Donate your high school teacher to me?
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 因为他是个地中海啊
Alice: Because he's bald like the Mediterranean.
Lucia: 啊OK好
Lucia: Ah, okay, fine.
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you have any battery left?
Alice: 露西呀你还有电吗
Alice: Lucia, do you have any battery left?
Lucia: 嗯你在问我吗
Lucia: Huh, are you asking me?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Tasha: 这个在录着呢
Tasha: This is being recorded.
Jake: 你你你插掉
Jake: You, you, you unplug it.
Tasha: 直接插掉就行吗
Tasha: Just unplug it directly?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 还有60%
Tasha: Still 60% left.
Jake: 嗯行可以
Jake: Yeah, it's fine, go ahead.
Shure:  你看那个磁吸压到头发了
Shure: Look, the magnet is pressing on the hair.
Lucia: 我打算把那个串珠还是买一串
Lucia: I'm planning to buy another string of those beads.
Lucia: 好吧如果他来得及到
Lucia: Okay, if it arrives in time.
Lucia: 咱可能还能做一下那个水母灯
Lucia: We might be able to make that jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 再来点欧根纱
Lucia: And get some organza.
Alice: 我本来昨天想买的
Alice: I was going to buy it yesterday.
Alice: 然后发现跟我的啊
Alice: Then I found out it matches my...
Lucia: 啊我打算买一米的蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Ah, I'm planning to buy a meter of blue organza.
Lucia: 我可以在房间里面弄一下
Lucia: I can use it in my room.
Lucia: 然后剩下的就你如如果就算真的要做灯
Lucia: And the rest, if we really make the lamp.
Lucia: 它里面用的纱也很少
Lucia: It doesn't use much fabric inside.
Lucia: 就我们每个人可以弄一块
Lucia: So each of us can have a piece.
Lucia: 然后放在里面
Lucia: And put it inside.
Alice: 然后给他剪掉
Alice: Then cut it off.
Lucia: 对对就比较好看一些
Lucia: Yes, yes, it will look nicer.
Alice: 边角料可以旋转一下固定一下
Alice: The scraps can be twisted and fixed.
Alice: 然后贴贴
Alice: Then stick them somewhere.
Alice: 贴在什么地方
Alice: Stick them where?
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: That's right.
Lucia: 我觉得你昨天安利给我的那个桌布
Lucia: I think the tablecloth you recommended yesterday.
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: It looks really nice.
Alice: 嗯我也我也买桌布了
Alice: Yeah, I also bought a tablecloth.
Jake: 桌布桌布挂墙上
Jake: Tablecloth, tablecloth, hang it on the wall.
Lucia: 不是啦
Lucia: No way.
Lucia: 桌布当然是放在桌子上
Lucia: A tablecloth is obviously for the table.
Jake: 你们有桌子吗
Jake: Do you have a table?
Alice: 我有一个小的
Alice: I have a small one.
Lucia: 他有小桌子
Lucia: He has a small table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 四十乘
Alice: Forty by...
Lucia: 我打算配一个塑料的小方桌
Lucia: I'm planning to get a small plastic square table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就会能轻一点
Lucia: So it can be lighter.
Lucia: 也不是很贵
Lucia: And it's not expensive.
Lucia: 因为我那个架子实在是太丑了
Lucia: Because my current shelf is just too ugly.
Jake: 明白
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 无法改造我觉得
Lucia: I don't think it can be remodeled.
Alice: 我觉得我们这个户型还挺好的
Alice: I think our layout is pretty good.
Alice: 因为比较小就
Alice: Because it's quite small.
Shure:  往下东西
Shure: Move things down.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice: 哎东西呢
Alice: Hey, where are the things?
Jake: 我们也整点喝的吧
Jake: Let's get some drinks too.
Jake: 哈哈给给您倒点咖咖啡给您倒点水
Jake: Haha, let me pour you some coffee, or some water.
Shure:  谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Katrina:  这咖啡吗
Katrina: Is this coffee?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  这好像昨天晚上调的
Katrina: It looks like it was made last night.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: This is it.
Jake: 这些应该都用过
Jake: These should have been used.
Jake: 来吧我们
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 我们最后一名做到
Jake: Our last one is done.
Katrina:  我怎么做到老板
Katrina: How did I do, boss?
Alice: 最后一名
Alice: The last one.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我也不做
Jake: I'm not doing it either.
Jake: 就是呃我们最后一名开始
Jake: So, um, our last one starts.
Jake: 呃介绍自己的礼物然后第一名
Jake: Um, introduce your gift, and then the first one.
Jake: 呃大家秀一轮之后然后第一名开始挑
Jake: Um, after everyone shows their gifts, the first one gets to choose.
Jake: 对对对我们排名了
Jake: Yeah, we ranked them.
Jake: 我们有电量96的
Jake: We have 96% battery.
Alice: 到1-2
Alice: Down to 1-2.
Alice: 嗯我在你后边
Alice: Hmm, I'm behind you.
Tasha: 呃我不知道
Tasha: Um, I don't know.
Tasha: 写了一个东西
Tasha: Wrote something.
Tasha: 乱七八糟的东西
Tasha: A bunch of random stuff.
Jake: 笑口常开
Jake: Always smiling.
Tasha: 明信片
Tasha: Postcard.
Shure:  天下粮仓
Shure: Granary of the World.
Tasha: 种植套餐
Tasha: Planting package.
Katrina:  呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Tasha: 营养塔
Tasha: Nutrition tower...
Tasha: 营养土盆栽和培养米种这张卡片的
Tasha: Nutrient soil potted plants and cultivating rice on this card...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  这鼓好用吗
Shure: Is this drum good to use?
Katrina:  把这摆着
Katrina: Put this here...
Jake: 不要太玩
Jake: Don't play too much.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 你说这个鼓吗
Lucia: You mean this drum?
Katrina:  不是  蛊  虫子下蛊了
Katrina: No, "Gu," as in worms casting spells.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Shure:  这个怎么翻译成英文
Shure: How do you translate this into English?
Katrina:  100人就开始算塔罗了
Katrina: Once there are 100 people, they start doing tarot.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 营养土啊
Tasha: Nutrient soil.
Lucia: 是椰土那种吗
Lucia: Is it coconut coir type?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 香菇是长
Jake: Mushrooms grow...
Jake: 香菇是好
Jake: Mushrooms are good.
Tasha: 可以养狼蛛用
Tasha: You can use it to raise tarantulas.
Lucia: sorry狼蛛
Lucia: Sorry, tarantulas?
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 对就是养狼蛛是要垫椰土的
Lucia: Yeah, to raise tarantulas, you need to use coconut coir as a base.
Alice: 你有这爱好
Alice: You have this hobby?
Lucia: 我现在没养
Lucia: I don't raise them now.
Lucia: 我以前养过
Lucia: I used to.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
Jake: 你多大呀
Jake: How old are you?
Lucia: 被我养死了哈哈哈
Lucia: I ended up killing them, hahaha.
Lucia: 呃4只宠物
Lucia: Uh, four pets.
Lucia: 那个岂不是狼蛛不舍他们偷吃养的
Lucia: So the tarantulas wouldn't mind them sneaking in to eat, right?
Jake: 啊倒第二
Jake: Oh, second to last.
Jake: 倒数第二名
Jake: Second to last place.
Jake: 第二名吧
Jake: Second place, right?
Jake: 第二名
Jake: Second place.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 准备了一个手链
Alice: Prepared a bracelet.
Alice: 是帝王沙跟绿松石的哦
Alice: It's made of imperial sand and turquoise.
Alice: 朱砂
Alice: Cinnabar.
Alice: 就是古代皇帝批折子用的那个红色的那个颜料就是从这边提取的
Alice: The red pigment that ancient emperors used for decrees was extracted from this.
Alice: 然后绿松石就是蓝绿色
Alice: And then turquoise is blue-green.
Alice: 因为有铜跟铁的那些
Alice: Because it has those copper and iron elements.
Alice: 哎不是铜
Alice: Oh, not copper.
Jake: 啥
Jake: What?
Alice: 铜跟
Alice: Copper and...
Shure:  朱砂
Shure: Cinnabar.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 铜跟豆铜跟铁
Alice: Copper and, uh, copper and iron.
Alice: 然后他这个会呈现不同的颜色
Alice: Then it shows different colors.
Alice: 主要是我觉得朱砂比较辟邪
Alice: Mainly, I think cinnabar wards off evil.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 是这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 谁电量多来着啊
Jake: Who has the most battery power?
Shure:  啊我我我最老
Shure: Ah, me, me, I'm the oldest.
Jake: 你多少来着
Jake: How much do you have?
Shure:  我是十几
Shure: I'm in the teens, I think.
Shure:  好像
Shure: I think.
Jake: 挺好哎
Jake: That's good.
Jake: 你这啥玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Shure:  这个是一个乐器
Shure: This is a musical instrument.
Shure:  它是一个叫做沙球的乐器
Shure: It's called a shaker.
Tasha: 原来这个放到这一直就是你的呀
Tasha: So this has always been yours?
Katrina:  哈哈哈已经被玩过了
Katrina: Haha, it's been played with already.
Shure:  已经被大家玩坏了
Shure: It's already been played to death.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure:  然后他可以这个样子
Shure: And then it can be like this.
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Shure:  这是他的沙球作用
Shure: This is its shaker function.
Shure:  然后他还可以
Shure: And it can also...
Shure:  就是比如说
Shure: Like, for example...
Shure:  就是它会发出一些碰撞的声音
Shure: It makes some collision sounds.
Shure:  对然后
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Tasha: AMSR啊哈哈
Tasha: ASMR, haha.
Shure:  最最最酷炫的就是它可以摆起来
Shure: The coolest thing is that it can stand up.
Tasha: 好酷哈哈
Tasha: So cool, haha.
Shure:  然后配合摆动
Shure: And with some movement...
Shure:  再加上一些
Shure: Add some...
Katrina:  摇滚的东西
Katrina: Rock elements.
Shure:  一些一点点魔法
Shure: A little bit of magic.
Shure:  然后就可以打出不一样的节奏型
Shure: Then you can play different rhythms.
Shure:  就比如说像这个样子
Shure: For example, like this.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 来一段
Jake: Give us a piece.
Shure:  这是来一段
Shure: Here's a piece.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我以为你叫什么大大节了
Jake: I thought you were going to play something grand.
Lucia: 不应该来点这个才艺表演吗
Lucia: Shouldn't you perform some talent show?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  竹板这么一打呀
Shure: When you play the bamboo clappers...
Shure:  别的咱不夸
Shure: We won't brag about anything else.
Shure:  咱就夸夸咱那个狗不理包子
Shure: Let's just praise our Goubuli buns.
Shure:  哈哈这一种赛博快板吧
Shure: Haha, this is a kind of cyber fast talk.
Shure:  可能非洲人的快板就是长这个样子
Shure: Maybe African fast talk looks like this.
Shure:  哈哈哈这确实好像是一种非洲的乐器
Shure: Hahaha, it really seems like an African instrument.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  他的学名我忘了叫啥了
Shure: I forgot its scientific name.
Shure:  反正大家都叫它砂锤啊砂球
Shure: Anyway, people call it sand hammer or sand ball.
Shure:  然后这是一个静音的
Shure: And this one is a mute version.
Shure:  就是它就是这种橡木的
Shure: It's made of oak.
Shure:  然后正常可能会有那种金属的
Shure: Normally, there might be metal ones.
Shure:  或者塑料的
Shure: Or plastic ones.
Shure:  就是音色是不一样的
Shure: The tones are different.
Shure:  这个就比较不那么吵
Shure: This one is not that noisy.
Shure:  然后声音也稍微暖一些
Shure: And the sound is a bit warmer.
Shure:  然后送出一个留一个
Shure: So, I'll give one away and keep one.
Shure:  因为演出还需要用的
Shure: Because I still need it for performances.
Shure:  哈哈哈不能把吃饭家伙事丢了
Shure: Hahaha, can't lose my tools for making a living.
Jake: 你是什么演出要用
Jake: What kind of performances do you use it for?
Shure:  就一些现场的演出也会用到的
Shure: It's used in some live shows.
Jake: 哈哈就煮饭啊
Jake: Hahaha, just for cooking?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  制造一种氛围音的时候
Shure: To create ambient sounds.
Lucia: 好像ASMR啊
Lucia: It seems like ASMR.
Shure:  我再配合这手链给你
Shure: I'll pair it with this bracelet for you.
Katrina:  睡了
Katrina: Fell asleep.
Tasha: 睡了
Tasha: Fell asleep.
Lucia: 困了困了
Lucia: Feeling sleepy.
Alice: 摇酒天赋
Alice: Shaking cocktail talent.
Shure:  嗯好哈哈哈好
Shure: Hmm, okay, hahaha, alright.
Katrina:  然后介绍我的吧
Katrina: Then let me introduce mine
Katrina:  我就是前前前一段时间去成都玩
Katrina: So, a while back I went to Chengdu
Katrina:  然后去那个玉林路那一些古着店
Katrina: And checked out some vintage stores on Yulin Road
Katrina:  淘的一些
Katrina: Found some cool stuff
Katrina:  呃就是钥匙扣和胸针
Katrina: Uh, like keychains and brooches
Shure:  就是淘宝店淘的新东西是吗
Shure: So you got new stuff from a Taobao store?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina:  对淘就是他他那个开店那个店主
Katrina: Yeah, the owner of the shop
Katrina:  他们是自己设计的
Katrina: They design everything themselves
Katrina:  就是自己是一个设计工作室
Katrina: It's a design studio
Katrina:  然后就只有在他
Katrina: And you can only buy it there
Katrina:  们那里能买到
Katrina: Only from them
Katrina:  然后买的是大熊猫的大熊猫
Katrina: So I got this big panda keychain
Katrina:  这是钥匙扣
Katrina: And this brooch
Katrina:  这是一个胸针
Katrina: It's a bird and a cat
Katrina:  就是一个鸟和一个猫
Katrina: Not sure what it means
Katrina:  我也不知道什么意思
Katrina: Just thought it was cute
Katrina:  我只是觉得很可爱
Katrina: So I bought it for everyone
Katrina:  我就买回来送给大家
Katrina: Alright, that's it
Katrina:  好OK
Katrina: Okay
Alice: Lucy
Jake: 好96
Jake: Alright, 96
Katrina:  嗯抽口的话对这里面有一个marry me
Katrina: Yeah, and inside there's one that says "marry me"
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 不是marry me
Lucia: Not "marry me"
Lucia: 就是我本来是就是有一个小手做的耳钉
Lucia: I made these small hand-shaped earrings
Lucia: 然后对这个其实很简单
Lucia: It's actually pretty simple
Lucia: 就只要买打了孔的珠子
Lucia: You just need beads with holes
Lucia: 和这个这个耳针
Lucia: And these earring posts
Lucia: 然后拿热熔胶把它粘在一起就可以
Lucia: Then use hot glue to stick them together
Lucia: 对然后但是就是我我自己做完之后
Lucia: And after I made them, I thought they looked pretty good
Lucia: 我觉得这个还那个效果还挺好
Lucia: So I made several pairs
Lucia: 所以我做了好几对
Lucia: Since we needed gifts for everyone
Lucia: 然后刚好就是这边要给大家
Lucia: I thought handmade ones would be more meaningful
Lucia: 就是给大家准备礼物
Lucia: So I prepared one
Lucia: 我就准备了一个
Lucia: I think handmade gifts are more meaningful
Lucia: 感觉是自己的手做的话会比较有意义
Lucia: But then I wondered why I bought a drawer
Lucia: 但是为什么我又去买了一个抽屉呢
Lucia: instead
Lucia: 因为我发现这个盒子有点大
Lucia: Because I found this box a bit big.
Lucia: 当我把它放到这盒子里面的时候
Lucia: When I put it inside this box,
Lucia: 他们俩显得非常的孤单
Lucia: the two of them looked very lonely.
Lucia: 然后我为了增加开盒的时候的气势
Lucia: So to add some grandeur when opening the box,
Lucia: 我就又去买了一个抽壳放在里面
Lucia: I bought another decorative shell to put inside.
Lucia: 然后但这样一放
Lucia: But when I put it in,
Lucia: 就会完全挡住他们两个
Lucia: it completely covered the two of them.
Lucia: 所以就是对
Lucia: So yeah,
Lucia: 于是这个礼物
Lucia: this gift
Lucia: 就变成了一个复合装饰的样子
Lucia: turned into a composite decoration.
Lucia: 然后这个就很就是这个
Lucia: And it looks, well, it looks,
Lucia: 我觉得还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think it looks pretty nice.
Lucia: 因为它是那种丝绒的料
Lucia: Because it's made of velvet material,
Lucia: 就是穿很多裙子都可以搭配
Lucia: it can match with many dresses.
Lucia: 但是男孩子的话就不考虑了
Lucia: But for boys, it's not an option.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  行了
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure:  你怎么能定定义我
Shure: How can you define me?
Lucia: 对不起对不起我错了啊
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, my bad.
Shure:  我就是你看正好两个嘛
Shure: Look, it's just right for the two of them.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 没有想到这一次
Lucia: Didn't expect that.
Lucia: 那那那说明你也是可以试用的
Lucia: So that means you can try it too.
Lucia: 那大家挑选起来就没有顾虑
Lucia: So everyone can choose without worries.
Alice: 对呵
Alice: Yeah, right.
Shure:  好话都
Shure: All the good words,
Shure:  让你说完了
Shure: you said them all.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 那路亚开始
Jake: Then let’s start.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Jake: 这怎么挑的
Jake: How do we choose?
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑来着
Lucia: I thought it was a blind pick.
Jake: 咱盲挑
Jake: Let's go with blind pick.
Lucia: 感觉都很有特色的样子
Lucia: They all seem pretty distinctive.
Shure:  先说一句好话
Shure: Say something nice first.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  憋出来了
Katrina: It’s really squeezing out.
Jake: 那咱要不盲挑也可以要不
Jake: So, we can either pick blindly or...
Lucia: 我我我摇个骰子吧
Lucia: I'll, I'll, I'll roll a dice.
Lucia: 那就要不
Lucia: So, how about...
Shure:  行
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯可以抽到我自己怎么办
Lucia: Hmm, what if I draw myself?
Katrina:  一二
Katrina: One, two...
Alice: 再来一轮
Alice: Another round.
Katrina:  4
Katrina: Four.
Shure:  1234 对咱们
Shure: One, two, three, four, right?
Lucia: 对咱们
Lucia: Yes, right?
Lucia: 咱们的群呢
Lucia: Our group, right?
Lucia: 我放到我就在咱们群里摇好了
Lucia: I'll just roll it in our group.
Shure:  公平公正公开
Shure: Fair and square.
Shure:  sorry
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina:  特别可爱是不是
Katrina: So cute, right?
Jake: 直播摇骰子
Jake: Live dice roll.
Lucia: 2 我结果大家能看得到吗
Lucia: Two. Can everyone see the result?
Lucia: 发了一个
Lucia: Sent one.
Tasha: 看到了
Tasha: Saw it.
Alice: 二
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 二
Lucia: Two.
Alice: 谁是2
Alice: Who is two?
Lucia: 按介绍说明
Lucia: According to the instructions.
Alice: 我是2
Alice: I'm two.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 谢谢可馨
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 啊这个包装也好好看
Lucia: Ah, this packaging is so pretty.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 色子是在表情里吗
Lucia: Is the dice in the emojis?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  表情里
Katrina: In the emojis.
Jake: 那我们第二
Jake: So, our second...
Jake: 第二名来挑
Jake: Second place will pick.
Jake: 倒数第二名来挑
Jake: Second to last will pick.
Shure:  哈哈你挑的你都都不那什么了
Shure: Haha, you picked it, you didn't even say anything.
Shure:  客套话都不说直接闪了
Shure: Didn't even say polite words, just left.
Katrina:  我
Katrina: I...
Katrina:  哈哈迫不及待啊
Katrina: Haha, so eager.
Katrina:  会直接搜筛子
Katrina: Will directly search for dice.
Jake: 这是真色子 假色子每次都能摇6
Jake: This is a real dice. Fake dice always roll six.
Shure:  哎你这是固定三的
Shure: Hey, is this fixed on three?
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: Really?
Katrina:  什么叫固定3
Katrina: What do you mean by fixed on three?
Jake: 那再再忍一下你自己
Jake: Then just bear with it a bit more.
Shure:  一二哎
Shure: One, two... hey
Shure:  不是3是我  3是我
Shure: It's not three, it's me. Three is me.
Jake: 等一下我再再再摇一下看是固定的吗
Jake: Wait, let me shake it again to see if it's fixed.
Alice: 不是吧不是
Alice: No way, it's not.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, it's not.
Jake: OK那那行那行
Jake: Okay then, that's fine.
Katrina:  还是3
Katrina: It's still three.
Lucia: 还是3
Lucia: It's still three.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Shure:  你没有表这个表情吗
Shure: Didn't you show this expression?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake: 咬出一个亿
Jake: Bite out a billion.
Lucia: 哦咬出一个亿
Lucia: Oh, bite out a billion.
Katrina:  给我自己
Katrina: For myself.
Shure:  那就3吧
Shure: Then let's go with three.
Jake: 就三三好
Jake: Three, okay, three is good.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina:  哈哈哈每天晚上你会听到我在房间
Katrina: Haha, every night you can hear me in my room.
Shure:  没事我在你楼下
Shure: It's fine, I'm downstairs.
Jake: 好那到你摇吧
Jake: Alright, it's your turn to shake.
Jake: 你倒啊
Jake: You pour it.
Shure:  我我摇吧还是
Shure: Should I shake it or...
Jake: 你客套话呢
Jake: Are you being polite?
Shure:  客套话就是
Shure: Being polite means...
Katrina:  谢谢大家
Katrina: Thank you, everyone.
Shure:  大家每个都非常的棒
Shure: Everyone is really great.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then...
Shure:  让我实在难以割舍
Shure: It's really hard for me to let go.
Shure:  选哪个割舍其他的
Shure: Choosing one and letting go of the others...
Shure:  都是一种
Shure: It's all...
Katrina:  演上了
Katrina: He's acting.
Shure:  我是几 四
Shure: What's my number? Four.
Shure:  1234 呀
Shure: One, two, three, four, yeah.
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  这么可爱的送给你
Katrina: So cute, giving it to you.
Shure:  哪有
Shure: No way.
Katrina:  送给你哈哈送给你
Katrina: This is for you, haha, this is for you.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 达成了交换
Lucia: The exchange is complete.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we...
Shure:  剩下二位就变成交换了
Shure: The remaining two will exchange.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 你得给我
Alice: You have to give it to me.
Alice: 然后他再给你
Alice: Then he will give it to you.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Shure:  完了
Shure: Done.
Shure:  没抽到洋鼓很可惜
Shure: Too bad we didn't get the drum.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就收拾收拾准备出发
Jake: Let's pack up and get ready to go.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  你这个要导数据吗
Katrina: Do you need to import this data?
Jake: 要
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  你之前要倒一会啊
Katrina: You need to do it for a while first.
Tasha: 这钱我也不知道怎么啊
Tasha: I don't know what to do with this money.
Tasha: 就是好看
Tasha: It just looks nice.
Shure:  卡掉
Shure: It got stuck.
Jake: 呃先先带回带回去
Jake: Uh, first take it back, take it back.
Jake: 然后带到一楼
Jake: Then take it to the first floor.
Jake: 放到那个
Jake: Put it in the...
Tasha: 你可以把它
Tasha: You can put it...
Jake: 盒里边
Jake: In the box.
Tasha: 那个是书法课上面老师
Tasha: The calligraphy class teacher...
Tasha: 呃统一买的
Tasha: Uh, bought it for everyone.
Lucia: 哦可以好奇一下写的什么
Lucia: Oh, can I be curious about what's written?
Alice: 笑口常开
Alice: "Always smile."
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it's so pretty.
Lucia: 写的好好
Lucia: Written so well.
Alice: 回眸
Alice: Looking back.
Jake: 啊谁写的
Jake: Ah, who wrote it?
Jake: 你写的哦
Jake: You wrote it?
Lucia: 微微写的
Lucia: Weiwei wrote it.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: So pretty.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Shure:  是不是有点太短了
Shure: Isn't it a bit too short?
Alice: 也差不多
Alice: It's about right.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 就大家把礼物放到自己房间
Jake: Everyone, put your gifts in your room.
Jake: 然后下去再一起结束就结束了
Jake: Then come down and we'll finish up together.
Katrina:  放到自己的房间
Katrina: Put it in your own room.
Alice: 是上一年
Alice: It was last year.
Alice: 去年冬天写的
Alice: Written last winter.
Tasha: 对哎我
Tasha: Right, I...
Jake: 我跳舞了
Jake: I danced.
Alice: 今年是甲醛
Alice: This year is formaldehyde.
Jake: 在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: Dance outside and turn back.
Shure:  回眸
Shure: Turn back.
Jake: 你们得在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: You all have to dance outside and turn back.
Jake: 然后拍拍照
Jake: Then take pictures.
Jake: 拍完照最后一天放PPT
Jake: After taking pictures, we'll show the PPT on the last day.
Alice: 我念对念惯了
Alice: I'm used to reciting it right.
Jake: 对就是pick lick是跳舞对吧
Jake: Yes, pick lick means dance, right?
Jake: 准备好防晒准备好
Jake: Get ready with sunscreen.
Jake: 呃拍拍照准备最后一天放PPT准备好
Jake: Uh, take pictures and get ready to show the PPT on the last day.
Jake: 对就是手机拍拍照
Jake: Yes, take pictures with your phone.
Lucia: 为什么我会砸到我自己的手
Lucia: Why do I keep hitting my own hand?
Shure:  因为它长
Shure: Because it's long.
Shure:  哦不不不就是夹的
Shure: Oh no, it's because of the clip.
Jake: 呃对OK
Jake: Uh, right, okay.
Jake: 然后准备买肉
Jake: Then get ready to buy meat.
Lucia: 不行我还是会砸到自己的手
Lucia: No, I'll still hit my own hand.
Jake: 晚上还有烤串
Jake: There will be skewers at night.
Jake: BBQ晚上烤串加甜点
Jake: BBQ and dessert at night.
Tasha: 下午是要出去吗
Tasha: Are we going out in the afternoon?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina:  晚上还有披萨
Katrina: There will be pizza at night.
Katrina:  两个够了不用再点
Katrina: Two are enough, no need to order more.
Jake: 这下午茶是披萨
Jake: The afternoon tea is pizza.
Jake: 可能在外边你们走累了吃俩披萨
Jake: Maybe you guys will get tired from walking and eat two pizzas.
Katrina:  哦你说让披萨带
Katrina: Oh, you mean bring the pizza.
Katrina:  出去
Katrina: Outside.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is it okay?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Yes, it's fine.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我得换件衣服
Katrina: I need to change my clothes.
Katrina:  我得装这个东西没口袋
Katrina: I need to put this thing away, no pockets.
Katrina:  装裤子
Katrina: Put it in my pants.
Jake: 环绕声是吧
Jake: Surround sound, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一般拿个颂锅先duang
Shure: Normally, you'd just hit a gong first, like "duang."
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 还是双摄
Lucia: Still dual cameras.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 挺好水平挺高
Jake: Pretty good, high level.
Jake: 自带混响
Jake: Built-in reverb.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈这视频可以录吗
Lucia: Haha, can this video be recorded?
Lucia: 晚上睡觉的时候就用来助眠用
Lucia: Use it to help sleep at night.
Jake: 可以你这卖钱吗
Jake: Can you sell this?
Jake: 你要不你录一段
Jake: How about you record a section?
Jake: 卖钱
Jake: Sell it.
Lucia: 你开一个
Lucia: You start one.
Jake: 卖多少钱
Jake: How much will you sell it for?
Lucia: AMSR频道
Lucia: ASMR channel.
Jake: 这个卖多少钱
Jake: How much will you sell this for?
Jake: 你这个掉了
Jake: You dropped this.
Jake: 行啊
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  是要导数据的是吧
Shure: Do we need to import the data?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice: 现在就导吗
Alice: Import it now?
Jake: 对他们把东西放回房间
Jake: Yes, they need to put their things back in the room.
Jake: 然后把眼镜给解决
Jake: Then sort out the glasses.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we can finish up.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 放回去
Jake: Put it back.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we can finish up.
Jake: 再都
Jake: Then all...
Shure:  忘拿了
Shure: Forgot to take it.
Shure:  差点
Shure: Almost.
Jake: 不是放回去到下面一起结束这么回事
Jake: Not put it back, we need to finish everything together.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 充电宝呢
Tasha: Where's the power bank?
Tasha: 不愿意失去人群的
Tasha: Not willing to lose the crowd.
Tasha: 既然我也会抓住你
Tasha: Since I will also hold onto you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.